des stars l'émission des coûts dans
l'émission d'ardisson guette toujours
reste tiens c'est depuis la première de
doublure hier ce que j'ai fait les
chinois david bowie stephan eicher polio
oui il est balèze son carnet reste pas
de la meilleure des fêtes avait dit
cette année à lomé moi c'est différent
parce que je suis plutôt se préciser
dans dans les français derrière haga
alors attention je crois au plus bas
c'est jérôme à l'honneur au mans nantes
acquis non mais c'est là j'ai plus grand
chose parce que j'ai tout échanger avec
avec un copain contre un autographe de
patrick bruel
oui si vouloir lagarde a dit pourquoi tu
dis ça
bruel s'apprend pas deux et le cirque on
cannelle hall [ __ ]